[Applaudissements]
et
voilà vous aussi vous aimez faire la
cuisine ça tombe
bien imaginez vous êtes une très bonne
cuisinière un très bon
cuisinier vous avez un restaurant
restaurant étoilé et vous allez créer le
nouveau plat du
soir est-ce que vous préférez faire
votre nouvelle création avec ces très
beaux raviolis d'une excellente qualité
industrielle
ou est-ce que vous préfériez faire votre
création avec ces ingrédients que vous
trouvez en frac et que vous avez pu
choisir maintenant vous avez le rêve de
créer une montre pour cela vous devenez
horlogère ou loger certains le sont
déjà pour faire votre montre ou surtout
pour faire votre mouvement vous allez
choisir les ingrédients au vrac ou
c'est-à-dire les composants vrac mais il
y a un problème en au logeries il y a
pas de magasin en
vraque d'un côté vous trouvez des très
bons mouvements industriels qui sont en
parfait état de marche et qu'il ne faut
surtout pas toucher
de l'autre côté vous trouverez des
artisans horlogés qui font tous les
composants eux même et dont la montre
coûte au final le prix d'une voiture de
sport si ce n'est pas celui d'une
maison al audelà vous allez vous poser
la question mais comment je peux faire
ma propre montre mon propre mouvement en
se situant entre ces deux
extrêmes la réponse elle est Open
movement et je vais vous dire pourquoi
je vous en parle ce soir à l' fond et
pour cela je tourne le temps un peu en
arrière
attention voici
roman un autre temps qui part en 1992 à
la Valou pour travailler ce choix est
motivé par le fait qu'il m'était
impossible de d'apprendre le français à
l'école assurique mais j'étais possédé
par l'idée d'y
parvenir et aussi par l'idée de faire
une formation supplémentaire un peu plus
tard en français à la cha de
fond avec quelques mots en poche et 2
années plus tard j'arrive à la chaufond
pour faire la formation de technicien en
restauration d'horlogerie ancienne
d'ailleurs ici dans les ateliers du
musée et à ce moment-là je me suis rendu
compte d'une
chose je me suis rendu compte que la CHF
est une ville
particulière froide d'apparence mais
chaleureuse il est facile d'entrer en
contact avec les gens même pour un
suissalement comme moi ça m'a beaucoup
plu et j'y suis
resté après 2 années de formation et
après avoir travaillé 10 ans dans les
ateliers de restation d'or Logerie
ancienne chez Parman Fleurier je me suis
mis à mon compte en
2007 et à ce moment-là je me suis rendu
compte d'une autre
chose jusque là il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont partagé leur savoir-faire avec
moi pendant l'apprentissage à la betchou
au tech à la jfond les artisans du musée
tous ces gens je PARM J et encore bien
d'autres
et je suis venu à la question que vous
vous êtes posé
avant comment il est possible de faire
sa propre montre avec son propre
mouvement tout en restant
abordable j'étais face à à des rab au
lit et un rayon en vrac complètement
vide de là sont n deux idées la première
celle de faire ma propre montre avec un
excellent mouvement
industriel et la deuxième
c'est de faire un mouvement un mouvement
partagé en parlant de ce mouvement
partagé à trois amis horlogés cela les a
enflammé et nous avons créé
l'association open movement en
2009 le but était de construire un
mouvement dont les fichiers 3D et les
plans sont librement
accessible avec à la clé un kit de
composant
brut
qui donne finalement accès un peu au
composants à l'image d'un magasin
enrac aujourd'hui ce mouvement il est en
train de passer de la réalité virtuelle
à la réalité
réelle mais il fallait quoi pour arriver
jusqu'ici il Fall quo pour arriver
jusqu'ici voilà en 2009
en 2009 on a commencé oui ça fait il y a
un moment ça fait il y a 14
ans ça fait longtemps hein vous avez
fait quoi il y a 14
ans c'est presque un/5e d'une
vie nous on a fignolé l'idée technique
du
mouvement et ça c'était lors d'une
soirée appelée soirée secré des régleurs
c'était avec ces gens
tous des spécialistes et des passionnés
de
l'orlogerie après
ou
pas je perturbé ça devait être noir
après ça on a cherché comment euh
financer le
développement
alors
euh de je suis perdu pardon
pour
comment comment financer le
développement
ou c'est un peu un passage difficile en
fait parce que pour on a cherché on a on
a proposer de l'aide pour chercher du
financement et en fait on a accepté
cette aide mais au lieu de trouver les
financements on a trouvé des ennuis en
fait on était confronté à un gros
euh conflit d'intérêts et puis on a dû
stopper tout le
processus le prix de cette actionl
c'était au fait 2 années de perdu ça
pris beaucoup de temps mais suite à
cette mésaventure là on s'est résolu
fort du constat que pour faire une
montre il faut du temps et pas seulement
de l'argent et c'est de là on a changé
de stratégie nous avons créé un groupe
de
construction et là on a mis notre
savoirfire au
mouvement lentement mais
sûrement parce qu' en horlogerie on est
face à des réalité bien
spécifique le bien est l'ennemi du
mieux le bien est l'ennemi du mieux vous
entendez bien cela veut dire il ne faut
pas s'arrêter trop vite le parfait
existe
a qui disent le contraire il faut pas le
croire un autre réalité pour faire le
minimum viable product il faut aller à
98% 80% votre mouvement mécanique ne
marchera pas un seul centiè de millimè
pe faire en sorte qu'un composant est
inutilisablei des milliers de francs
dépens
pouren mais bon je coupe court la longue
histoire car le 21 mars 2021 on a enfin
pu publier la première 3D de ce
mouvement et DEP puis il réjouit des
gens sur toute la planète non seulement
les horlogères ou les horlogers mais
aussi les designerss et surtout aussi
les gens qui sont simplement des adeptes
de l'OP
source
c'est quoi le but exactement de ce
mouvement en fait quand on est horlogé
on n'est pas forcément
constructeur c'est pourquoi on a fait ce
travail de construction au sein de
l'association movement avec les
spécialistes jusqu'à ce jour on a
investi plus de
6000 bénévoles dans le dans ce dans ce
travail ou dans le
projet c'est un investissement à l'image
de de graines qui ont été plantées dans
un champ
ensuite pour que les graines ont pu
pousser les membres de l'association et
des médecines ont mis de
l'engré c'est-à-dire du financement
financement nécessaire à la fabrication
de tout ce qu'il faut pour 20
prototypes parce qu'ici on parle d'un
projet open source hardware c'est moins
commun est bien autrement qu' qu'un
projet open source
software il faut
fabriquer il faut fabriquer tous les
composants voici l'un de nos bénévoles
avec un tas de composant ce tas de
composant il pèse 1,3 g il vaut ainsi 30
fois le prix de
l'or alors l'avantage de l'OP source
c'est
quoi l'avantage c'est la production en
commun grâce à une certaine masse de
gens on peut produire les composants
ensemble les producteurs ils auront des
plus grosses commandes avec un seul
interlocuteur et de l'autre côté
l'individu a l'avantage d'avoir le prix
d' gros sans devoir courir
partout le gros avantage est évidemment
d'avoir les fichiers et les plans
disposition les fichiers ont déjà servi
à plusieurs travaux de bâelor on a
simplement pu les donner il y a pas
besoin de faire la police et les plans
comme ici peuvent servir à faire son
propre
outillage soit pour terminer les pièces
soit pour les fabriquer
soi-même alors maintenant vous vous
posez peut-être la question mais
pourquoi le travail une telle ampleur et
donner
librement plutôt que de la plutôt que de
le garder en
secret la réponse c'est est relativement
simple c'est pour le plaisir de voir le
savoirfire au
mouvement et les secret les secrets de
l'horlogerie suisse on peut quand même
pas les donner à toute la
planète l'horlogerie suisse c'est bien
connu pour ses
secrets l'origine de cela se trouve dans
les concours de Chronométrie ils étaient
organisés jusqu'au début des ann années
1970 dans les observatoires contonaux
comme ici celui de
nechatel jusque là la réputation d'une
marque s
mesurée par la précision d'un mouvement
de son
mouvement Fall pas parler de savoirfaire
horloger entre les
horlogés alors avec l'arrivée du et la
concurrence étrangère ces concours ont
été
abandonnés le temps il est
revollu et du coup je pense à un
horloger retraité qui me disit une fois
je n'ai pas de
secret je te donne simplement ce dont on
m'avait
donné alors mant non à l'air du tout
digital où tout le monde à l'heure sur
son
téléphone mais pourquoi on fait encore
des montres
mécanique autre frigo il se remplit
peut-être grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle il vous commande les mêmes
yaourts que vous avez toujours
mangé c'est certes
bluffant mais finalement frigo il
s'ouvre parce qu'il a une charnière
mécanique notre monde il est mécanique
et la mécanique horlogère elle est
particulièrement fascinante on a déjà
entendu ce mot plusieurs fois ce soir
elle est particulièrement fascinante
elle fait briller vos yeux et peut-être
encore un petit peu plus d'avantage ce
soir parce que vous avez la primeur de
voir le premier prototype qui
marche merci pour votre
attention